[Music]
and I'm out news please submitted by
who's reading this gene Matt do you know
a gun devil youtube channel with 24
million views is moving to where pornhub
yeah mm-hmm how up there is pornhub in
the porn website world is it like top 3
I don't know do they have non related
porn stuff on pornhub don't don't they
saying that 90% of Internet bandwidth is
porn content I think it's more like 74
70 yeah but then so I would just think
just in terms of all streaming pornhub
is probably super up there mmm is it
because of YouTube like the rules of
guns in my yeah so YouTube recently
announced changes in their policy
policies on content featuring firearms
are saying that now YouTube will
prohibit certain kinds of content
featuring firearms and that sucks so
does that mean we have to private our
gun channels you have a gun
I mean our gun videos we're just
shooting having fun intends to sell
firearms are certain firearm accessories
through direct sales or links to sites
that sell these items these accessories
include may include but may not be
limited limited to accessories and
enable a firearm to stimulate automatic
fire or convert a firearm to automatic
fire what and high-capacity magazines
the next bullet point is provides
instructions on manufacturing the
firearm and munition high-capacity
magazine homemade silencer / suppressors
or certain firearm accessories such as
those listed above this includes
instructions on how to convert a firearm
to automatic or simulated automatic
firing capabilities and the last point
is shows users how to install the
above-mentioned accessories or
modifications
oh so it's Gundy I why channels telling
you to do stuff that are slightly
illegal in some states also like they
can't get brand deals for anything now
because they can't promote sales yeah
so they gotta just move to another
platform but I don't think they have to
do they don't have to ban them if you
just don't put ads just don't put ads on
them that's just the climate all over
like with businesses like even I think
it was like FedEx was a supporter of the
NRA and then a lot of businesses were
like yo you got to stop being a
supporter of that of them or we're gonna
pull our business and go somewhere else
like it's like all across business what
about Marie Callender's are they
supported the NRA I don't know all the
car rentals are all that like they are
they still are yeah dude it's you it's a
big deal right now
I don't even understand I never it
confuses me when people like tie one
thing it's I do we're super cuts and
we're a huge supporter of the NRA
and the people that want me to go to
fantastic status it's like we'll have to
do anything we'll have the best fades
our super cuts that's it that's like the
same thing with chick-fil-a when the
owner was like we hate gay people or
we're gonna get that I was like if I was
gay I'd eat hell the chicken well it's
because you don't want them to be in
business anymore because we don't want
to or support them but you probably
never said they hated gay people though
or they support anti gay foundation no
the statement was that they were like
Christian and that they that that wasn't
a part of their beliefs but people took
that as like hey yeah so it was I mean
that that was like blown way out of
proportion
that's me like it's like you're
Christian but keep that out of your
public business entity you know I mean
like that's not that you can't say that
because Christianity or of religion in
general is a part of their life so for
then that would be wrong of them
religiously Union now it has Bible
verses or titles or whatever on their
bags in like cups and stuff so what
about like the the Baker those like I'm
not making a cake for your gay that's
different that's refusing services
before so that's discrimination
jiggly's yeah discriminating against
anybody you know so my thing is like I
didn't say we're not gonna serve gay
people sandwiches they were just like
well it doesn't they don't believe in
that that's all these like in high
school there's this thing that came out
or Tommy Hilfiger was hated chinks or
something or he's like super racist
you know how true that is yeah but for
me I was just like well I don't really
care because whoever designed this and
your team is [ __ ] sick I'm still
gonna buy it yeah you know that you're
not a protesting type of person though
you don't boycott you don't do any of
that I used to when I was dumbass like
maybe just like make up that test on
animals a lot of people don't buy that
yeah that's [ __ ] up
that's a direct relation I'm like the
makeup testing on animals it's not like
hey Tommy Hilfiger is skinning
Vietnamese people alive and using these
products to make their new fine that you
don't you're just like oh well that's
not what I do but there's a lot of
people that would boycott like the
boycott Nike the boycott Apple because
of just their business practices and
stuff I wish I understood because yes I
know a lot of sweatshop kids make Nike
shoes but no one's boycotting Nike yeah
but there's maybe a few people they do
know but almost everyone I know that
owns a pair of Nikes yep
they all know it's made by kids and
they're like I'm still gonna no way
personally I don't want a shoe that's
not needed by child through the best
they make the best ones they had the
little fingers that could put it through
the holes and stuff yeah
the attention to detail by kids is
pretty amazing if an adult touches my
shoe I don't want it yeah oh my god we
also have iPhones so yeah if you own an
iPhone you own a Nike you own any of
those things
yep we contribute here that's made then
yeah yeah the bank account like the
major banks like you got kids working
out the night not kids but with the way
that they use the money that you put in
the bank like they'll use it for [ __ ]
that you probably don't agree with true
because they're investing their money
everything that we consume is pretty
much hurting someone at this point yeah
a hundred percent but just be mindful
not everyone thinks to see people that's
who I am I'm a mindful guy but I wear
Nike everything and I don't I'd barely
work out it's fantastic that's my goal
in life is to always look like I'm going
to work out and look like I never work
out it built it doesn't mean to your
soul though you feel like accomplished
just that you put yourself in that
wardrobe I refused to I don't want any
like workout stuff because I don't want
to be a poser because people look at me
and be like you're [ __ ] fake and I
don't know
just like even regular leggings let's
say but suddenly your technical do you
want to get cuz you're weighing a
sweater uh-huh sweater okay which is
dependent so I'm doing what it's
supposed to do you guys ever buy workout
stuff to motivate you to fit into it I
do that but I never actually get into
the body that I want to I by sizing okay
so when I went to from like small to
medium I kept buying small cuz I'm like
there's no [ __ ] way I'm ever wearing
medium I'm gonna work back to a small
and network oh that's a dope I just have
a lot of I I basically have a boutique
store we're taxing it so if anybody
wants to go shopping let me know he's
going my closet you know what I do like
I end up buying something I gotta look
fresh when I'm working out but then I'm
like I don't want to ruin these nice
clothes so I work out in my old [ __ ]
clothes and I put those on for regular
wear yeah that's exactly when I did come
to the gym like three times in my life I
just wore like shorts and a t-shirt I
never understood like pretty well that's
cuz you look good at it so you can
[ __ ] wear it but me I'm just in a
big-ass t-shirt you don't count
but Fitness and clothing is blue the
[ __ ] up man like it's kind of crazy how
like now it's like you can't go to the
gym unless you're matching your [ __ ] I
know bad I look like a piece of [ __ ] in
the gym I wear like the oldest t-shirt
ever because it doesn't really for me
it's like I go there once a year anyways
because I were a barbell yeah I got a
sponsorship like box Oh season one
barbell brigade I wore the sweat pants
all the time while playing games anyway
so yeah this YouTube channel it's called
in range TV they recently said that
they're gonna be moving over to pornhub
because pornhub hat has a history of
being proactive proactive voice in the
online community as well as I'm really
resilient and robust video streaming
platform that's interesting why don't
they just make gun hub or something cuz
like pop-ups you know those porn pops up
yeah video we get like 16 pop-up
adjusters yeah then I see like headline
saying that you're most likely to get
like a [ __ ] ton of viruses and your
computer crashing down if you're always
on porn site and every time I watch a
gun video I'm still get distracted you
start watching porn or you're just
trying to like learn about how to fix
your gun and then like there's porn
that's all over on the side to want like
your family's around I want to teach my
kid how to like load a gun properly you
just didn't teach them a lot of video
Gina what is it you would teach them I
don't know I think just the climate is
pretty crazy right now with the whole
like shootings and everything being
there's just bad press on it so
everything is just bad at demonize show
any of that on YouTube what they'll show
a [ __ ] dead body hung on a tree dude
as long as it's education although you
could pretty much show anything on you
to rest fast you like [ __ ] yeah sir
yeah I saw a video of a guy getting a
catheter put into his dick yeah why
would you look for that cuz I was just
curious
sometimes yeah yeah there's like this
other thing where they're showing their
Brazilian waxes and you women go through
a lot just to get that [ __ ] I saw that
because my friend became an aesthetician
and then she I was I hadn't talked to
her in a long time and I said well what
do you do now she sent me a YouTube clip
and it was just another one after that
and another one after that and they go
like into the [ __ ] and everything
they wear it's [ __ ] brutal do they
laser the [ __ ] yes I wish I could get
waxed she's been huge it was so funny we
did a save it though that moments God
forever
because it's really lean forgetting that
[ __ ] rip and it pans over to face our
tears laughing did when we got our
armpits wax all of us started bleeding
yeah we're bleeding it points thank God
for laser you do so good you look WAY
buff do that be done a laser at then
like forever get rid of it mmm how did
you care nothing about it I don't know
it feels it feels weird when it's like
oh yeah like I'm a pretty natural person
I gotta bring the nose waxing see you
guys absolutely now [ __ ] know the thing
I did it shake it out but mine aren't
even that long to be kidding mine's
pretty long you could [ __ ] bungee
jump it was like it's done like mine
creeps out of the nose hole like a
bucket toothbrush so glad you don't have
I'm like the hairiest probably Asian
yeah I do when you pull it out it's like
a [ __ ] like just a fuzzy head wax
stick with the fuzzy head you know what
I use I use the the nose option on the
electric yeah it tickles my nose but I
gotta blow my nose because I have all
these yeah you just stick it up there
and you yank it out it's things your
eyes water up but it's nice but that big
salt all of them at the same not all of
them because you still had the ones in
here here goes all the way back here
yeah it's you still have those back
there it's just doing the ones out here
so nothing sticks out but what I learned
is your nose gets a lot more drippy when
you have no hair in there dude the
purpose yeah yeah but I think for girls
too you have thinner hair so it's not
like so aggressive like we have phishing
scam yeah my nose here's a [ __ ] thing
what do I always try to show you never
look at it can I bring this in for an
episode taking part my nose hair is like
my head hair yeah it's pretty thick but
so is my pubes in my arms mine are like
that all that bug my pubes it's [ __ ]
thick as [ __ ] I feel like I got the same
does I believe like what's doing yeah
when I pluck it I go like every time ago
ooh
you pluck it out yeah sometimes it's
just one straggler Oh too much trouble
to be like attractive dude it's just
like you got a dead [ __ ] man watching
everybody just be blind maybe great the
world would be better the world is a
very tick tick
[Music]